problema 71 cuál es el valor de x en el
siguiente triángulo muy bien nos marcan
que el triángulo es rectángulo y además
que es isósceles porque estos dos lados
miden lo mismo entonces estos dos
ángulos miden lo mismo y además deben
sumar 90 grados para que con este de 180
y por lo tanto como son iguales y suman
90 cada uno es de 45 grados 45 grados
bueno resulta que este tipo de
triángulos es bien conocido este tipo de
triángulos es un tipo de triángulos que
son muy conocidos vale si tenemos un
triángulo que es rectángulo isósceles o
sea este lado mide lo mismo que éste y
este lado mide digamos entonces la
hipotenusa mide raíz de 2 ya raíz de 2
pero no tienes que creerme así con fe
ciega vamos a hacerlo para que veas de
dónde salen estas razones vale bueno en
realidad este simplemente es utilizar el
teorema de pitágoras así que no va a ser
nada muy sorprendente tenemos que x al
cuadrado más x al cuadrado es igual a 10
al cuadrado haciendo pitágoras aquí
entonces 2 x al cuadrado es igual a 100
dividiendo entre 2 al cuadrado es igual
a 50 y por lo tanto x es igual a raíz de
50 eso está en las opciones no entonces
seguro quieren que lo simplifiquemos
entonces x es igual a raíz de vamos a
ponerlo como 25 por 2 para que quede
aquí un cuadrado entonces x es igual a
raíz de 25 o sea 5 por raíz de 2 raíz de
2x igual a raíz de 25 raíz de 2 si aquí
esta opción b bueno y te cuento esto de
que es un triángulo bien conocido porque
a veces es más rápido recordar
recordar estas razones y simplemente
aplicar eso en el problema por ejemplo
si aquí sabemos que 10 es raíz de 12
entonces basta a dividir 10 entre raíz
de 2 para obtener x y 10 entre raíz de 2
cuando es entre raíz de dos vamos a
multiplicar por raíz de 2 arriba y abajo
raíz de dos entonces nos queda 10 raíz
de 2 entre 2 ese 2 se está escondiendo
entre 2 que es igual a 5 raíz de 2
entonces esta es otra forma de obtenerlo
si nos acordamos en qué razón están
estos lados del triángulo 45 45 90 pero
bueno si no te acuerdas de eso siempre
tienes la opción de volver a usar el
teorema de pitágoras vamos al problema
72 dice cuál es el valor de x en
pulgadas
aquí tenemos x un ángulo de 30 entonces
este triángulo es de 30 60 90 30 60 90
vale y por lo tanto conocemos la razón
entre sus lados ya habíamos platicado de
esto en otro vídeo pero como pequeño
recordatorio en los triángulos de 30 60
90 tenemos que si esto mide y estoy acá
mide 12 y estoy acá me de raíz de 3
porque otra vez no tienes que creer me
lo en realidad ya lo demostramos y más o
menos la idea era era completar este
triángulo para que se hiciera un
triángulo equilátero lo cual podemos
hacer porque este ángulo es de 60 y este
de 30 y claro este de 90 entonces si
éste era y éste era y esther ayer vale y
entonces este de acá
otro lado del equilátero también tiene
que medir 12 y bueno el tercer lado
salía con el teorema de pitágoras
entonces éste era más o menos la idea
vamos a aplicar esto que ya sabemos en
el triángulo que tenemos aquí si éste es
de 7 pulgadas el día acá mide 14
pulgadas
14 pulgadas y siempre el que es más
difícil de recordar es el tercero el de
raíz de 3 y entonces bueno digo aquí
simplemente pudiéramos poner 7 x raíz de
3 y entonces la respuesta sería ah pero
vamos a hacer lo que haríamos si no si
no recordamos los de raíz de 3 si no
recordamos eso entonces tendríamos que
aplicar el teorema de pitágoras con x 7
y 14 entonces tendríamos x al cuadrado
más 7 al cuadrado es igual a 14 al
cuadrado entonces x al cuadrado más 49
es igual a
196 14 al cuadrado 14 x 14
según yo si es 196 pero lo checamos 4
por 14 56 10 por 14 140 entonces al
sumar esto nos queda 196 va
bueno entonces ahora nos queda que quizá
al cuadrado es igual a 196 menos 49 son
números muy grandes creo que por eso es
bueno recordar esto pero bueno vamos a
hacerlo 196 menos 49 que hay que restar
este 9 para 67 llevamos un este 4 se
hace 5 para 94 y 0 para uno es 1
entonces x al cuadrado es igual a 196
menos 49 que es igual a
147 es mucho hice todo bien espero no
tener un error de cuentas y x al
cuadrado bueno ya vamos a ponerle x es
igual a raíz de 147
y entonces x es igual a raíz de haber
147 es como 150 pero le faltan 3
entonces es 49 por 3 si estoy aquí es
igual a raíz de 49 o sea 7 por raíz de
3x es igual a 7 por raíz de 3 y entonces
ahí tenemos otra forma de encontrar este
lado si no nos acordamos de las razones
de este triángulo especial vale bueno
vamos a pasar al problema 73 a veces si
es bueno aprenderse algunas cosas yo
siempre estoy esté en contra de
memorizar pero en estos casos creo que
es útil funciona para este examen y para
el este y para otros pero bueno dice un
cuadrado es circunscrito alrededor de un
círculo circunscrito es que está vamos a
hacer el dibujo entonces así aquí está
el círculo
el cuadrado circunscrito más o menos a
ver si sale bien más o menos es algo así
y eso está suficientemente bueno bueno
aquí debería ser tangente aquí también
aquí también aquí también va entonces
ahí tenemos el dibujo y nos preguntan
cuál es la razón entre el área del
círculo y el área del cuadrado pues nada
más queremos la razón entonces déjame
proponer aquí un radio r vamos a
proponer aquí un cierto radio r si esto
mide r también para acá me dé r porque
aquí también tenemos un punto de la
circunferencia entonces el lado del
cuadrado mide 12 r entonces el área del
cuadrado el área es 4 r al cuadrado es
elevar 2 r al cuadrado vale bueno y lo
que nos piden es la razón entre el área
del círculo lo voy a poner el área del
círculo y el área del cuadrado va si
recordamos un círculo de radio r tiene
tiene área pi por radio al cuadrado
y por radio al cuadrado y un cuadrado
bueno este cuadrado tiene área 4 r al
cuadrado como ya lo vimos aquí su lado
al cuadrado entonces es re cuadrada se
cancela con el re cuadrada y nos queda
igual a pie entre 4 opción de g muy bien
aquí también fue bueno recordar lo del
área del círculo verdad entonces a lo
mejor no es tan malo recordar cosas
memorizar las bueno problema 74
problemas 74 en la siguiente
circunferencia a b y c de los segmentos
a b y c d son cuerdas que se intersectan
en el ok se intersectan aquí dice si es
igual a 5 esta medida si en eso quedó
feo si esta medida es 5 b es igual a 12
es igual a 6 cuál es la longitud del
segmento de queremos queremos la
longitud de este segmento de acá bueno
vamos a utilizar una propiedad de la
intersección de cuerdas de un círculo
que no vamos a demostrar pero que es muy
útil vale dice lo siguiente si estoy
aquí es x entonces el producto de los
segmentos que quedaron cortados en cada
uno de los segmentos es constante es
mejor escribir lo que decirlo o sea a lo
que me refiero es que 5 x 12
5 x 12 es igual a 6 x x es igual a 6 x x
y con esto pues tenemos una ecuación en
x 5 x 2 es igual a 60 60 es igual a 6 x
dividiendo entre 6 tenemos que x es
igual a 10 entonces la respuesta es sí y
bueno no lo voy a probar porque es un
poquito latoso pero si quieres puedes
intentarlo por tu cuenta más o menos la
idea a lo mejor hasta hasta ya te sople
demasiado o te dé mucha información de
cómo de como es resolverlo como probar
esta propiedad pero más o menos la idea
triángulos ace y bebés van a ser
semejantes ya comparten este ángulo de
acá por ser opuesto por el vértice y
además de este ángulo de acá que es
congruente a este de acá porque a ambos
abren la cuerda a de entonces jugando un
poco con esa semejanza y son triángulos
semejantes que oficie congruentes pero
no son semejantes jugando con esa
semejanza puedes obtener estas razones o
bien es esta propiedad vale bueno te lo
dejo para que lo intentes a lo mejor
luego haga un vídeo de de cómo se hace
vamos finalmente con el problema
75 va a ser el último de este vídeo dice
la recta rv esta de acá están gente a la
circunferencia de centro a este centro
centro en el punto b en este punto de
acá y además sabemos que ve de es un
diámetro muy bien verde es diámetro y lo
que nos preguntan es la medida del
ángulo cb r
r este ángulo de acá muy bien pues aquí
simplemente es darse cuenta darse cuenta
que ave es un radio como bd es diámetro
y es el centro entonces ave es radio y
por lo tanto ésta que es la tangente es
perpendicular al radio al radio que pasa
por el punto de tangencia entonces si
éste se llama x vale si este ángulo se
llama x tenemos que xy 25 son
complementarios suman 90 grados entonces
la medida del ángulo x más 25 grados es
igual a 90 grados y por lo tanto la
medida del ángulo del ángulo x es igual
a 90 menos 25 o sea 65 grados vale una
vez más esta es una de las propiedades
que es bueno recordar las un radio
siempre es perpendicular a la tangente
que pasa por el punto de tangencia del
punto de tangencia a donde llega ese
radio vale entonces esto de aquí es de
90 grados bueno entonces es 65 y la
respuesta es
vamos a dejarle hasta aquí nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo para terminar con
este examen de geometría de california